er ist gerne der underdog also jemand
der immer ein bisschen den ball flach
hält um es dann den leuten zu zeigen
warum das so ist und natürlich noch viel
mehr antworten auf eure fragen jetzt im
community video mit gut bis akoya qlp
möchte wissen mit welchem deiner
starcraft 2 konkurrenten verstehst du
dich am besten also an dicht events
versteht man sich mit allen immer
relativ gut jetzt mit denen man nicht so
gut klar kommt ich werde sagen am besten
und handlungen mit zucker den kenne ich
schon ewig da soll ich glaube der 2004
schon einmal ein event denn starcraft 1
zusammen und seitdem malt immer wieder
hin und wieder getroffen und so weiter
aber auch in die mails oder und
natürlich hat mit dem neuen aus meinem
team aus monty und so weiter also an
sich soll von einem alles ganz schön
laut gefragt egal wie gut die auch ist
er bleibt immer der underdog gefällt ihm
diese position um ehrlich zu sein
gefällt mir das schon hermann weniger
druck beim spielen dann halt alle
erwarten muss man sowieso verliert und
dann und dann aber doch gewinnt dann ist
halt auch immer ein schönes
erfolgserlebnis
jetzt hab ich den leuten doch gezeigt
geglaubt haben mich verlieren auf der
einen seite halt wenn man schon ins
spiel geld und denkt ja ich muss
gewinnen weil das alle warten dann hat
man halt immer druck und es wird
eigentlich schwieriger cloud ging noch
mal gut trainiert in den letzten wochen
extrem viel hatte ein bestimmtes ziel
welche einheit von hot es wird das
gameplay von starcraft 2 am meisten
beeinflussen und hörst du eigene musik
während du sagst dann zeigen wir euch
keine musik weil
das ablängen bürger und ja ich trainiere
wirklich sehr viele moment was einfach
daher nicht dass sich in den nächsten
wochen sehr viele tänzer also auf der
gamescom spiele ich ja überhaupt pc
gespielt und sonntag ist manfred erst
dann sms und danach die woche sind die
psp und für nadal sich halt viel zu
trainieren
ich würde mal gerne obwohl die mit dem
vorstehenden addon heart of the swarm
noch mal ein comeback für mich gegen
protoss kommen sieht und ob es einen
bestimmten grund gibt warum er außerhalb
von europa in offline turnieren schon
längst nicht mehr gewonnen hat möchte
wissen wie das genau mit hat es vom
aussieht muss man als schauen wenn die
beete herauskommt geteilt wird immer
noch so viel geändert so viel balance
dass das ist schwer zu sagen ist der
bachelor nicht gesehen habe er sah ganz
gut aus für mccain protoss von daher bin
ich sicher dass auf jeden fall wieder
versuchen werde aber ob das sein hat
funktioniert wie gut das dann wirklich
ist muss man halt einfach sehen afinitor
an die wie war das damals mit dem rtl
bericht über dich man weiß ja dass bei
rtl eine menge gefegt werden kann nicht
muss wenn die protagonisten freaky genug
rüberkommen wurde alles so erzählt wie
du es dir vorgestellt hast
ich fand dass man lohe pnc stank
wenigstens erwähnen hätte können weil
das seine eigenarten sind
also die erdölproduktion verlief
eigentlich ziemlich gut
wie waren denn die leute die bei mir
waren und die mich auch auf dem land
begreift haben und insgesamt bin ich
sehr zufrieden mit dem beitrag also ja
mal ein paar sachen bis zum vereinfacht
dann dargestellt damit die zuschauer das
hat doch verstehen aber irgendwie nicht
verdreht oder sonstwas und noch mehr
gaming klicks um zb mit dennis schneider
hasuobs auch sehr erfolgreich bei
starcraft 2 der erklärt dem community
video was sein erstes game war und
natürlich noch viel mehr und sehr lustig
das community video mit den 2570 die
meine nämlich sie würden mit dem vb
tälern einen säbelzahntiger remix machen
wie sie das mein ernst lustig oder mehr
so transzendentale ihr werdet sehen im
community video mit den drei bestand